hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong I am Mark Ellis
on a very sunny day here in Southern
California and Jacqueline Coley my
esteemed co-host today it's sunny not
just because of the weather outside but
because the movie franchise we get to
talk about today beloved is a strong
word for every movie in these
properties but the first one we just
have such such fond memories of that
summer in 1993 when we all first saw
that you could make dinosaurs from
mosquito DNA or it was it was Dino DNA
in mosquitoes that were then in Amber
fill in the code with some frogs and
boom you got a T-Rex back on Earth
very true very true listen I don't think
that the science ever held up but as
long as they keep trotting BD Wong out
I'm with it he's just the guy that you
believe can do this stuff with and now
once we get to Jurassic world Dominion
which is one of the reasons why we're
doing this very special Jurassic Park
episode where yep we're ranking all six
of these dinosaur movies from Jurassic
Park in 93 all the way through Dominion
in 2022 Dominion is going to be an
interesting Tomato Meter watch because
as of the recording of This Dominion is
about to drop in theaters Nationwide so
we have some reviews from the critics we
don't have any audience reviews yet but
a couple days ago when our lovely Tim
Ryan our review curation manager was
kind of looking at the list and
disseminating what the ranking as far as
Tomato Meter was of Jurassic Park movies
Dominion was 88 fresh now we're
recording this and it's 73 fresh so it's
dropping I think it might land somewhere
around just barely fresh or just almost
fresh but here I'm going to give you the
rankings Jacqueline and then we're going
to bring in our our very very special
guest today who is a good buddy of ours
friend of the show he's got a couple
movies coming out so Jurassic Park is
1990 1993 92 certified fresh the OG is
still the top dog 92 Jurassic world
Dominion still in second place as of me
talking about this 73 fresh Jurassic
world from 2015 to 71 percent fresh the
Lost World Jurassic Park which is part
two that is 53 rotten Jurassic Park 3 is
48 rotten and Jurassic world Fallen
Kingdom the second entry in the Jurassic
world franchise is 47 rotten everybody
got that so far good usually I turn it
over to Jacqueline for a synopsis about
what Jurassic Park's about but I'm not
doing it I refuse it's pretty much I
mean you just any quote by Dr John
Hammond is and then any retort by Sam
Neal or Jeff Goldblum or Laura Dern is
pretty much all you need to know I build
a park because I thought it'd be cool to
have dinosaurs then the scientists are
like uh we probably shouldn't have done
this and then chaos ensues So speaking
of chaos our guests today
um just a wonderful human being start to
finish who is in not one but two movies
coming out right now and they're about
to make the film festival rounds a
Bogota trip and always Lola are the
movies that are being starred in by
Andrew Guy Andrew I've also seen you
worldwide announcing Esports you
occasionally are next to me when we're
talking movie trivia with the schmowdown
and now you're here talking about
Jurassic Park you and I got to see
Dominion together and we enjoyed a
hearty bucket of popcorn yeah yeah
thanks for having me guys and yes we did
watch Dominion together and it was
interesting because I think we came out
with one uh feeling of the movie and
then we ran into a group of friends who
had the polar opposite feeling of said
movies so it'll be fun to kind of break
it down and see where it ends up on the
Tomato Meter as you said it's dropped
already a decent amount just in the next
few days or I guess in the last few days
so I'm excited to keep watching the
trajectory and this is this is why
Jacqueline knows this as well as anyone
when when I see a movie in a theater I
want to leave I want to be by myself
with my own thoughts and I want to run
into a gaggle of friends who's going to
try to sway me in one direction or the
other Jacqueline are you a big reviewer
of movies as soon as you leave the
theater are you looking for the Gaggle
or are you trying to avoid the Gaggle
um
but I also work and Rotten Tomatoes
where people give it very freely so you
kind of have to have a little bit of an
energy diet on whose opinion you let
matter and I will say that there are
it's a very short list but yeah if I see
Justin Chang after a movie I'd be
interested to see what he has to say
about it I'd be equally as interested to
hear what you have to say about it but
certain gaggles at the at our press
screenings yeah
[Laughter]
I don't know who gave this rumor that I
enjoy people in all forms I'm much more
of a particular sampling of the human
race like well we all have energies
and dogs more than anything else remind
me of the dinosaurs now in Jurassic Park
we're gonna get into that and some of
the issues that I have with Fallen
Kingdom and Dominion uh we're not going
to spoil Dominion by the way I want
everybody to know that because the movie
just came out this past weekend we're
not going to spoil Dominion we might
give some light plot points but nothing
too in depth of unite yet seen the movie
you can still continue to listen to the
episode so Andrew I'm going to start
with you really quick you heard my
ranking as far as the Tomato Meter goes
of Jurassic Park film start to finish
one through six I'm just going to ask
you if you agree is Rotten Tomatoes
right or is Rotten Tomatoes wrong about
Jurassic Park being number one and then
Fallen Kingdom being number six uh I I
love to say it but I believe Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong when it comes to this
list of six that we have I mean the top
of it number one I don't think anyone's
ever gonna argue that but I think it
does fall apart just a little bit two
through six okay Jacqueline Coley is
Rotten Tomatoes wrong about their Tomato
Meter ranking I mean in the senses
that's what people said at the time
obviously not it's so weird with
rankings to say if it's wrong I'll say
it feels right how about that it feels
right because that's what it does it
feels right like I can't argue one way
or the other because I think after one
or two the bar is low and I don't think
anybody met it
Korean podcast episodes to back me up on
that yeah but some met it more than
others so I'm gonna say Rotten Tomatoes
is wrong about the rankings Andrew has a
great point I think we all know it's
going to be number one on all of our
lists but then from there two through
six the water is going to get a little
choppy and that's why we have Tim Ryan
like I said he's our expert review
curation manager at Rotten Tomatoes he's
going to tell us what critics we're
saying of the time of these various
releases starting back in 93 all the way
through our current world with Jurassic
world Dominion so Tim it's all yours
with him before I get into a very brief
overview of the Jurassic franchise I
want to note that the critics and
audiences have been almost in total
Accord on every film with critic and
audience scores in most cases just off
by single digits let's get into the
numbers the original and still the best
reviewed is Jurassic Park from 1993.
it's certified fresh at 92 percent on
the Tomato Meter and it has a 91
audience score next up is the Lost World
Jurassic Park from 1997. it's rotten at
53 on the Tomato Meter and it has a 51
audience score we covered that one on a
previous podcast Jurassic Park 3 from
2001 is rotten at 48 with a 36 audience
score giving it the largest gap between
critics and audiences Jurassic world
from 2015 is fresh at 71 with a 78
audience score we covered that one a
couple weeks back Jurassic world Fallen
Kingdom from 2018 is rotten at 47 with a
48 audience score and it is way too soon
to tell where Jurassic World Dominion
will fall with both critics and
audiences but at the time of this
recording it's fresh at 88 albeit with
only eight reviews so what are some of
the things critics said about the
Jurassic movies in a fresh review from
Jurassic Park from 1993 Stephen Ray of
the Philadelphia Inquirer wrote the
earth-shaking footfalls that these
lizard kings are palpable and terrifying
Spielberg's crew of dinosaur effects
artists has conjured up a Mesozoic
Menagerie whose realism outdoes anything
in cinematic history however in a rotten
review for Jurassic world Fallen Kingdom
David Sims of the Atlantic wrote the
viewer might be left with a few decent
frights but at this point the Mortal
Terror of Spielberg's original film has
diminished Beyond repair
so that's a rundown of the Jurassic
series let's kick it back to Jacqueline
and Mark two podcasters who know that if
there was a movie franchise about a
flock of condors and an island they
wouldn't have anything to say back to
you folks
I love that term from Steven Wright
Mesozoic Menagerie that is one to put in
the back pocket and uh try to bust out
if you want to sound smart let's get
right to it let's get right into the
Jurassic Park franchise our ratings one
through six our favorite our least
favorite movies and our favorite Dino
kills right now with movie talk
[Music]
I don't know producing Lucy's going to
get upset at me but can we just start
with our favorite dinosaur kill which
just starts there before we get into our
rating what is your favorite it could be
from any of the six movies Andrew Guy do
you have one favorite dinosaur kill and
yes I'm giving you the first round draft
pick so you have the lawyer on the
toilet sitting there available that is
sort of like the I don't know Cooper cup
of this draft I mean you literally just
said it so am I supposed to still say it
or should I go to my second choice
because the lawyer on the toilet is the
ultimate ultimate greatest kill in
Jurassic Park history I mean the from
the he left us he left us you're like oh
dude this asshole's gonna get it you
can't just leave kids with the
Tyrannosaurus Rex and then go to a
bathroom to hide and and also I think in
all these movies back in the 90s or
every great action movie there was
always the you know he's gonna die guy
and this movie had two you know he's
gonna die guys and it was the lawyer
because lawyers usually do get it in
these types of movies but also also
Newman Wayne Knight our good friend uh
with the squeal at the beginning so I
will land on the lawyer with the toilet
since you said it I don't want to steal
your guyses but I definitely have some
more up my sleeve yeah poor poor Dennis
nedry uh Jacqueline the theater erupted
every time back in 93 when that Warrior
got his comeuppance and when you watch
the movie again the way Jeff goldblum's
Ian Malcolm delivers the line when you
gotta go you gotta go like the way he
says it he knows that this guy's a goner
he knows that he is going to get his
comeuppance what is Jack and Coley's
favorite kill in any of the Jurassic
Park flicks uh my favorite kill in the
Jurassic Park franchise can it be a
dinosaur it doesn't have to be a dime I
mean if you want to go Dyno on Dino well
because when when uh T-Rex comes in his
very like Terminator to Arnold
Schwarzenegger way at the end of
Jurassic world that's a pretty great
moment if I'm being honest
um and yeah it is also I want to correct
the record I was not thinking we were
adding Dominion into this because like I
want to be clear that thing has eight
reviews it wasn't until I was listening
to Tim that I was like are we including
that because that's dumb first of all I
just want to go on record that 88 and
get a hold of it's 73 now I checked this
morning it's 73. that score is going to
age like milk listen
needs to be really clear about the
silliness and slight stupidity of
thinking that that movie's ranking even
in that like 73 In This Moment is gonna
hold up sorry so I want to be really
clear I just thought it was first uh the
first one and then second one Jurassic
world so delete my previous thing yeah
that list is wrong as hell just based on
timeliness
Daniel's ranking in in just a sec but
I'll tell you my my favorite Kill from I
love the one in Jurassic world that we
disseminated when we covered that
specific movie with our good friend
Winston it it but it's it's the way that
they just milk that poor woman who died
really for like we weren't mad at her
but a pterodactyl or something just
picked her up and just tortured the hell
out of her but my honestly my favorite
kill in any of the Jurassic Park movies
I go back to the first one and it's
Muldoon the guy who's sort of like the
great white Hunter who is out looking
he's he's doing the noble thing he's
trying to rescue is whoever else is left
out there but he runs across the
Velociraptor and and he real and he
knows as a hunter he knows that these
things are great at hunting in packs and
when he gets face to face with one and
he just says clever girl he knows he's a
goner he knows that he has been
outsmarted and it's just a really cool
moment of like one Warrior respecting
another even though they're different
species they both have this like code
and that's pretty much Muldoon like
shaking hands and being like hey you got
me good game there was nothing I can do
[Music]
clever girl
[Music]
I love how Spielberg somehow sold us on
the fact that he even had a chance
against the Velociraptors because it
really felt like he did when he was out
there for a bit with a shotgun and
tracking him in the sweat but no he was
a goner just you know you look like you
know what you're doing in the jungle
when you have those khaki shorts but uh
you're no match for a naked Velociraptor
especially when they come in pairs so
let's get into this ranking a little bit
I want to start with your favorite movie
which is obviously going to be Jurassic
Park the original for all of us and then
Where Do We Go From Here Andrew do you
have your your two through six locked
and ready to go I think I do it's it's
really tough because part of it is
Nostalgia and then the other part of is
like is this actually a good movie right
like Jurassic Park three and uh was like
the first Jurassic Park movie I remember
seeing in a theater right so I have
strong feelings for it but we all know
it's not very good so I think if I'm
gonna go because I watched every one of
these movies and I had to watch Lost
World twice this last week I want to go
it's just not great but it's still
Spielberg it's still shot better than
the other movies they're still like the
weight of the dinosaurs like we're
talking about they're still like these
beautiful camera angles and like the
shot through the log when he's going
after Julianne Moore all that stuff so
like after all said and done I think I
have to go Lost World too and am I just
going all the way through here all the
way through baby because you're so your
new ones as well so I'm going lost world
is number two I'm gonna go Jurassic
world is number three and then I'm gonna
go
think Jurassic world Dominion then
Jurassic Park 3 and then Jurassic Park
world of Fallen Kingdom because like
look we all want to see a couple bad
dinosaurs die you cannot kill I mean you
said this to be Alice when we walked out
of dominion you cannot kill all those
dinosaurs at the beginning of Jurassic
world Fallen Kingdom it is devastating
and and then the brachiosaur at the end
crying in the smoke I wanted to turn it
off it was it was devastating yeah
Jacqueline I I feel like if this was the
first Jurassic Park movie that came out
that big Fallen Kingdom then I probably
wouldn't have cared that the volcano
went off and killed this island Full of
Dinosaurs because I hadn't got to know
them yet but I've known these Beasts for
the last 25 years of my life and now
they're kind of like dogs to me and I
don't want to see any of them in pain
and so Fallen Kingdom I understand what
we're going for with that shot I
understand what we're going for with the
sadness that it's a Paradise Lost
situation but it's just that that final
shot of this this island that is on fire
from a volcano and we can't save all of
them and that giant Brachiosaurus I just
want to give him a hug I just want to
give him a hug so Fallen Kingdom would
be my least favorite Jurassic Park movie
um I'm I think I'm gonna put Jurassic
Park 3 next and so I'm gonna have
Andrew's bottom as well Jurassic Park I
feel like Jurassic world Dominion might
be that next one and then the lost world
and then Jurassic world is my second
favorite Jurassic world because I I felt
the the the Colin travara what he did
right was the Nostalgia mixed with the
newness I love that we went bigger I
love that we followed some of the same
beats of the first one but it felt like
the most plausible to me that hey we had
this thing happen a generation ago but
don't worry it's fixed now and it's
operating smooth and then obviously
number one would be the original
Jurassic Park Jacqueline Coley your
rating of the Jurassic Park franchise
uh uh Park World they could do a battle
royale for third and the one that's left
living I'm sorry for the kids nowadays
they need to do a squid game like type
you know thing if you don't know about
Battle Royale which was before Hunger
Games and now this one has to play games
except it's not with teenagers whatever
anyway listen
yeah that's it the other ones are just
all trashed varying degrees they may
have good in them but they are just
varying degrees of trash as well I'm
kind of previewing a little bit my
thoughts on Dominion but in all honesty
I would pull it out of the muck quicker
than the other three the other three
have way too much muck Steven Spielberg
doing Nostalgia of himself because he
was too broken by Schindler's List I'm
glad he went through something through
this movie and came out better on the
other side it does not make up for the
fact that they had a black girl kick a
velociraptor in the face while doing
unbalanced Bean bars that is still the
stupidest premise in the history of any
movie let alone a movie that already is
founded on a pretty stupid premise so
park world who cares I feel like y'all
figure it out I don't care like they're
all tied for fourth and that is a
horrible tie yeah if I was gonna go the
worst scene Andrew in any Jurassic Park
movie I mean that that shot with Fallen
Kingdom is pretty tough but it is just
so random and I still haven't gotten
over the lost world where and and again
I love that the Jeff Goldblum has this
daughter who is a apparently a
world-class gymnast and why would you
have her get cut why is she cut from her
high school that's what I was thinking I
was like what is this competitive ass
Elementary School that this girl is they
were like no she's you're gone sister
give up on your dreams I mean you're
nine weren't they in like San Francisco
I'm like way to give it up for the like
very liberal Bastion of San Francisco
that is some real like West Texas energy
just so you know as a Texan I'm gonna
tell you
um also too where's the daughter in
Dominion I'm I did not see her pop up in
that movie and I'm very good question
you know look I I feel like Jeff
goldwoman Samuel and Laura Dern it was
wonderful to see them back in Dominion
um even if it's just kind of like
coasting at 60 speed where it's like
yeah we're here we're gonna do some
stuff we're gonna deliver some lines and
be some crucial plot points Dominion I
the the reason why I like Dominion
better than Fallen Kingdom is because I
think Dominion had a first of all
Dominion trying to pick up the Baton
from the end of Fallen Kingdom didn't be
like what the hell do we do now
um I I feel like that was admirable the
way that they tried to do that and try
to wrap everything up I think Fallen
Kingdom got the most bloated and
sprawled out and just ridiculous towards
the end which is saying something at a
franchise where at one point we did have
talking dinosaurs in a dream sequence in
Jurassic Park three so if if we're
looking I want to take you all back to
93 though because I do want to honor the
first movie just talk about whether it's
a scene whether it's a character a quote
Andrew what is it about the first
Jurassic Park that the first when you
think about that movie This is the first
thing that pops into your head is it a
character is it a line is it a sequence
I mean that that moment where Sam Neil
grabs Laura Dern's head and turns it
like their reactions when they see the
brachiosaur and the dinosaurs for the
first time and the music swells and you
get Hammond saying welcome to Jurassic
Park Park when he's almost like on the
verge of tears that for me even like I
was watching again last night it just
makes me feel like a kid I'm like God I
love movies I love good movies and this
is like the epitome of that in this
scene but the thing that it all boils
down to man is that T-Rex head that's it
like literally just the head of that
T-Rex is scarier than anything else that
happens in the other five movies which
is why it will always be the best that
thing is scary still to this day you
know 30 years later Jacqueline
Jurassic Park honestly
Sam Neal terrorizing that young child at
the beginning yes
to spill out and the reason why is like
maybe I'm a bit of a writer and I I do
apologize I read Jurassic Park very a
long time ago like I was reading
Jurassic I was I was reading Michael
Crichton when I was reading Jackie
Collins and if you don't know who either
of those authors are you get an idea of
how old that was but and so I don't
remember what was in the book but that
is such a great bit of character
Exposition along with story Exposition
because it sets up one of the most
dramatic moments it sets up your guy's
death later Mark the the big hunter guy
but it also really epitomizes who that
Sam Neil character is the curmudgeon I
just want to be about my dinos but we
got to deal with you snotty-nosed brat
so that like the people that are most
interested in dinosaurs are children so
imagine having a child dating
paleontologist like just the idea of
that is so comedic it's like why don't
you go get Mr Rogers to also hate
children yeah Jacqueline does it does
Sam Neal in this remind you of any uh
podcast co-host that you might currently
have
oh my God I mean I'm not gonna go that
far because you would not terrorize
children it's so not that it's so not
that but I definitely think if you met
the wrong child that you wanted to
terrorize yeah I definitely I'm like
you're enough of a comedian for folks
that don't know comedians are just drag
queens without the makeup you all are
shady y'all are shady and so you would
destroy that child
drag queens without the makeup that's my
favorite I mean no offense but they are
just as catty they are just as like
drama-filled
we have an insular community that we
protect and talk trash about at the very
same time if I'm looking at Jurassic
Park and I'm thinking like you have all
these great kind of money shots I still
love Mr DNA and I still call them
dinosaurs more often than I call them
dinosaurs I love that that's it's such a
setup for all these great lines like we
were so preoccupied with whether we
could didn't stop to think of whether we
should and life finds a way and and all
of that stuff but the scene that I think
really captures an audience and the one
that I still viscerally remember even
more than the head turn which is just an
amazing all-time moment in cinema is
seeing dinosaurs for the first time the
the the
suspense-filled spielbergian genius that
is that kitchen scene when Lex and Tim
are trapped in there with the Raptors
and the Raptors open doors and it's like
oh these These are really smart these
aren't just like huge lizards these are
really smart carbon-based life forms
that we're looking at and to watch Lex
and Tim try to outsmart them with the
mirrors and it was just such a pressure
packed moment that that and also
watching Sir Richard Attenborough just
crush a gallon of ice cream because
because what else are you gonna do your
Park is a disaster you can't drink
alcohol right now because that's
dangerous and so what are you gonna do
well the freezers are melting everybody
else is getting eaten I guess I'm gonna
have some rocky road before it's all
said and done and such that is exactly
what you would get get a child like ice
cream this is not the moment for
pistachio or buttercream no [ __ ] kids
get like the most like bubble gum get
cotton candy get Rocky Road
so if we pick it up from the the rest of
that trilogy right so the rest of these
sort of original trilogy where we had
Spielberg return for the Lost World then
we had Joe Johnson step in in Jurassic
Park three I will say this and I already
made the joke about the Talking
Dinosaurs sequence that you get in
Jurassic Park three I had heard such
negative things about that movie for
whatever reason I just never saw it
until fairly recently it really isn't
the worst movie I've ever seen it's
still entertaining and the dinosaur
effects still hold up it's ridiculous
but I still enjoyed watching the movie
do and and so I feel like that is closer
to the lost world than I think people
want to give it credit for am I crazy I
I think I don't know I'm gonna let you
answer this one true because me
personally I think look again we talked
about this movie on the podcast and poor
Perry nimrock I think I broke her soul a
bit with how much I didn't like that
movie but whatever it should be all
right uh her love for Jurassic goes way
deeper than anything I or anyone could
say so I know that but I will say this
about it I don't think it's a bad
dinosaur movie or even a bad adventure
movie I think it's a bad Jurassic Park
movie that's the problem I have with
Jurassic world and that's like what I've
heard so many people say about every
Jurassic Park movie after the first one
and I and I totally agree is that like
it's not a bad dinosaur movie it's not
even a bad like action movie from that
time period it's just not as good as the
first one and and same to be said about
Lost World you know the fact that I I
said I had to watch it twice this week
to like convince myself and I think I
really did have to like convince myself
mainly with like the fact that some of
it was still practical and then the
lighting and the shots like I was saying
before more but at the end of the day
they're just not even close and as as
computer technology got better the
movies kept getting worse which is still
like mind-boggling to me because you
figure when you go back and you watch
the 93 Jurassic Park and you're like wow
that CG has not aged well but this
movie's dinosaurs are still better than
the ones that we got you know yesterday
or whatever when we saw Dominion I think
that's the craziest thing when you look
at just lost world and in Jurassic Park
3 is that as technology got better the
movie still got worse and I think it's
because they relied on it more so like
yeah I agree with Jaclyn Jurassic Park 3
is like a fine dinosaur movie it's a
fine action movie it just doesn't really
feel like Jurassic Park it doesn't feel
like you're being introduced to this
wonderful world it feels like you're
just like all right here we go again
who's gonna live who's gonna die how do
you recommend Jurassic world Dominion if
if somebody's asking you hey you know
I'm a fan of Jurassic Park I love the
first one like everyone and then I've
been in and out of the rest of the
movies do you recommend Dominion to him
or Andrew do you just say no just go see
top gun Maverick again it
definitely I would say that that is
something that would happen no matter
what
um I actually said that on Monday night
when I left the thing I was like it's
great but if you're looking for that
thing
I don't know if that if the girl's gonna
give you that every time basically this
is what it is Jurassic world is the girl
that's gonna give it to you 60 of the
time and she's gonna give it to you well
but if you need it a hundred percent of
the time Top Gun is that girl yeah I
mean we were in the lobby afterwards and
I was just staring at the open doors of
top gun Maverick after we walked out I
was like man I could just go in there I
could fix all of this right now you just
feel so much better I again I actually
again I'm not even saying like it's
apples oranges I'm just saying that like
certain people are not gonna dig
Dominion like there's gonna be 40 of
people who are those people y'all talk
to I think I think what I tell them is
that like you know it's good to see
everyone back on screen together again
even if like you said Ellis they're only
given like 60 they're kind of just like
whatever we're here but they're still
great I still love all three of them
um and then I I think the other positive
thing was that it was I mean God it was
it was a little longer than I would have
liked it to be but at least there was a
ton of action so I couldn't stop and
think about things that didn't really
make sense to me like the wristbands as
we were talking about before Ellis and
how they can't seem to track who owns
what wristband and what wristband opens
what door at a multi-billion dollar
facility it's cool not a big deal my
laundromat can do that but whatever
we're not we're not trying to set the
standard here you feel like when you go
to work at Google they just give you one
card that opens every door at Google hey
you need this for everything
plot point that we're really upset about
with Jurassic world Dominion but the
dinosaurs do look great and there's a
lot of cool dino fights and so if you're
going to these movies to see dinosaurs I
just think that we're Beyond The Pale if
we're saying I just want that feeling of
suspense and excitement and newness that
I got with 1993 because when Jurassic
Park came out it was a revolution in the
way that CGI was done on the big screen
and it opened the door for virtually
every giant Blockbuster that you still
still see today where you could do
things starting with Jurassic Park that
a lot of folks thought could never be
pulled off on the big screen it's why
George Lucas was on set one day at
Jurassic Park and he's like oh I guess I
should get cracking on the prequel
trilogy because now I can pull it off
and it's an exciting thing thank God for
that it was then Andrew it was then and
it was now and and when you go back and
revisit it the thing that did always
Direction about the original that we
just lose a little bit of something with
particularly with Fallen Kingdom and
Dominion is any concern or care for the
human characters like I don't know if
it's just me being the gruff you know
aged man that I've grown into or maybe I
just don't have as much optimism for the
human race I am fully rooting for the
dinosaurs when I go see Jurassic world
Fallen Kingdom and Jurassic world
dominion and I couldn't say that about
the original Jurassic Park like I cared
about the humans in the same way that I
cared about the three human beings that
were thrown on a boat together in the
first Jaws yeah that's actually a really
great Point yeah it felt like Chris
Pratt was just like a movie star and
same with price Dallas Howard and
they're both good they're both
charismatic and engaging enough but yeah
it's agreed the other the old characters
were real people they felt like really
real people and and if they felt a
little nuanced like Ian Malcolm for
instance it's like the delivery and the
performance was just so perfect that it
was like it felt like his note was like
just know that you always want to talk
but you don't know what you're going to
say but it's still going to sound great
when you say it whereas like with Pratt
and and Bryce Dallas Howard it just felt
like they were these Hollywood cutouts
of what you thought you wanted
characters to be so if we look at
honorable mentions now is are there any
other moments in maybe staying away from
the first Jurassic Park in any of the
other films that you say that that is
why I love a big Blockbuster that has a
lot of dinosaurs and if there were a
couple of those moments that I won't
give away with Dominion there were a
couple cool shots there are a couple
smaller nods to the original that
blinking you might miss it but if you
were paying attention for you sort of
got rewarded with that but I still go
back to Jurassic world I just I love
looking at the park I loved thinking
like oh that is a place that it's been
safe for years I would love to take my
nephews and my niece there like I feel
like I would be one of those suckers
that's like well I know they had an
accident you know 30 years ago but it's
fine now it's it's just like this
Disneyland I'll take the kids there now
I just love having that thought would
you really do that like actually after
what you said earlier about children why
am I surprised you and Judy Greer are
just sending the kids off into the
Wilderness no I'm going with them I'm
not Judy Greer I know I'm going with
them and here's the other thing I would
say is that unlike say Galaxy's Edge
which I'm not going to go to until I get
to go to with the niece and nephews I
would go to Jurassic World by myself
first or maybe I'd call my friends
Jacqueline and Andrew and say hey adults
trip singles trip y'all want to go and
then we could all go together and
experience it good I would so never be
there Jacqueline you would go if we were
going you would go
if there's a film festival there you
would go it's just showing all the
Jurassic World movies
like literally markers
I would be so against it and someone's
like yeah but you get to see Babylon by
Damien and chazelle like first would you
go like that's like the thing that gets
me to like compromise my morals is like
let me see a movie early dang it Mark
well that's the real question though is
because I feel like in in the first
Jurassic Park you know Grant and Sadler
and Malcolm didn't really have an option
because they got flown to this private
island and it's like you're you're
getting the the the red carpet treatment
they're handing you champagne and
whatever you want to eat and so then
Hamlet's like we all want to go into the
park it's like of course you're gonna go
in the park like you just kind of assume
and you're along for the ride Andrew are
you going into the first Jurassic Park
as it's presented in the movie and are
you going to be a tourist at Jurassic
world I don't know man I mean like I no
I don't even need to figure out
something like bungee jumping let alone
skydiving okay so if there's a Jurassic
Park in real life I'll watch it on TV
I'll watch people in their like live
streams and I'll watch that go awry I
will not go there I will lie like not
only does it look incredibly humid I'm
gonna die so like I got I don't want I
don't want those things to happen to me
Martin they say this is ridiculous you
would totally go it's like going to the
most Kick-Ass interactive Zoo you've
ever been to to see animals that that
we're not on Earth for 65 million years
y'all are both going to that if I'm
paying y'all are both going I mean if
you're paying and there's a film
festival
dilemma but I don't like Zeus to begin
with like I'm not about this life it's
just uh no it's actually dangerous you
could go wrong at the zoo regular I
think a dude got attacked by an
orangutan yesterday and a ring attack
okay so what happens when the
Velociraptor is like oh it's out of its
cage
I'm not telling you to get too close
that guy got too close to the orangutan
that video is hilarious somebody has
dubbed it over to where the gorilla is
like mouthing like words to him and it
is one of the most like
well first of all I would be panicked
but it is hilarious to watch that Panic
dubbed over with like great Tick Tock
dialogue oh it's a better story if it
was like a velociraptor instead of an
orangutan sorry it would be a better
story it's the absolute best is watching
Zoo accidents as long as they're you
know
um medium I don't want to see anybody
die but like to see humans occasionally
get their comeuppance and again I didn't
have that feeling when I saw the
original Jurassic Park so if we if we
pick up the ball from Dominion look
these movies still make over a billion
dollars are we gonna get more Jurassic
Parks I don't want to pose the question
should we get more Jurassic Park because
I think that we're all like we need this
thing to go away for about a decade and
then see where we're at but when we
eventually do get another Jurassic Park
What's it gonna look like what should it
look like Andrew man that's that's a
tough one
um I'm assuming that if they were going
to keep going the best way would
probably be to lean on Maisie like her
character right because she came from
Fallen Kingdom she showed up in Dominion
instead of just keep going with Pratt
and Bryce Alice Howard I feel like
they've maybe run their course at least
for now maybe they could come back like
these original Three did but I I more so
want to see like the post-apocalyptic
world of of like the dinosaurs have been
around for like 20 years now and it did
not work out as we all knew it would not
the war like things are closed there's
no more Banks there's no more like going
to concerts and stuff it's like people
trying to survive like in Planet of the
Apes and stuff like that that's kind of
what I would like to see I guess maybe
like a darker look on it because the
other thing about these movies is that
like as I referred to the first one it's
like it's still terrifying that movie is
still scary even the Velociraptor scene
which the CG hasn't aged great is still
scary and I didn't feel scared for the
rest of the movies so if it could maybe
add a little bit more of that like real
world problems with other people along
with Dinosaurs you know the whole like
walking dead outline of like who's worse
is it the dinosaurs or the people I'd be
cool with that I guess in like like you
said like 10 years please I don't know I
think wipe the a slight clean but I
think there's a way to wipe the Slate
clean and go smaller like I just don't
feel like we need to expand Jurassic
world like why don't we get into the
first days of Hammond deciding to be
crazy you know what I mean like why
don't we go into like let's start it
from like almost this sort of like
Westworld prequel type situation I feel
like that is a more interesting place to
go at this point than it is to like put
distance because I just don't think that
we could honestly really actually put
enough distance ahead that it wouldn't
feel weird does that make sense yeah I
like that I like that answer that's I
like that answer well you're never
getting another Park situation because
now you know it just even at the outset
of dominion we've just seen what's
happened with Fallen Kingdom like we're
on the mainland we're all over the place
life's gonna find a way these dinosaurs
ain't going anywhere so you don't really
need a park for them anymore and
nobody's going to want to go visit a
park when you just walk outside and
chances are there's a T-Rex walking down
your street so I think it would have to
be a full reboot the problem with that
being I would say say that we're closer
to like a Terminator situation where
nobody ever felt like touching the
original Terminator or Terminator 2
Judgment day they just tried to figure
out a way to make a sequel to those
movies even if it had the redcon
previous movies so I think it might be
like a Terminator or a Halloween
situation where it's like hey remember
those other movies that we had yeah
those are a lot of fun no now we're
gonna make a direct sequel to the first
Jurassic Park in a different way I think
that's what's gonna happen but I think
it's going to be about 10 years before
that goes down
um I mean but I think that's a direct
sequel it's interesting but my my thing
is is that means that the big three is
never involved again is that what you're
saying yeah I I and I think it would be
taking a different way to where they
don't want anything it but it might be
your picking up from the events of the
first Jurassic Park I mean you can I
just don't think you can pick up
anything from Jurassic world it's a it's
a fun movie but it chewed a lot of meat
off the bone it was kind of like me
eating a chicken wing with a bone in it
where I'm not gonna eat everything I'm
just gonna eat the good parts then throw
way to where there's just nothing really
you can do with that left like the end
of Jurassic world is pretty much okay we
got to pick up these pieces for the next
two movies and then we're done there's
nowhere else to go so with Jurassic Park
I think it's either going to be thank
you for watching these other movies
here's a direct sequel to the first one
or it's going to be picking up in more
of what Andrew said where it's 10 years
later from dominion and dinosaurs are
pretty much running the planet
yeah I feel I feel like the more that we
I think about that and even after what
Jacqueline said it just it does seem
like it would just get messy and dirty
but hopefully if it is 10 years down the
line with a different director and all
that stuff it could be really cool a
soft reboot works sometimes a soft
reboot works like the way they did Mad
Max Fury Road like it doesn't even have
to be that
clear like it's clear that there are
some of the events that happened in the
Mad Max series that happened to our
version of Max that we see in Mad Max
Fury Road but it's clear that a lot of
them didn't just based on the timeline
and honestly I think they can do that
and I think it's clear that uh
regardless of what kind of dinosaur
movie we're going to get whether it's in
the Jurassic Canon whether it's
something like Dragonheart where it's
it's still it's a talking dinosaur with
Sean Connery and the effects look cool
it's gonna be hard to top what we got in
the summer 93 with the original Jurassic
Park on that note I'm going to test all
of our Jurassic Park sensibilities
particularly when it comes to audio and
when it comes to what does a dinosaur
sound like I believe our expert engineer
Brian Perez has a few dinosaur sounds
queued up that he's gonna play and then
we have to weigh in on which dinosaur we
think it is
I think that was the uh it's not a
Stegosaurus I think that's a Triceratops
that's hurt it's not feeling well in the
first movie okay go with that because
that just sounded not like let's say a
brachiosaur but I think you might be
right Ellis that was a Triceratops it
was a Triceratops Triceratops yeah I am
one for one that was the Triceratops we
just got word confirmation from
producing Lucy all right let's hear that
second noise again and I'll let Jaclyn
kick this one off foreign
[Music]
was up first with this next dinosaur
noise know your dinosaurs
sounds like me eating KFC I'll be 100
honest the rapper in there
um I don't know is that I don't even
know what they're called but are those
all the little birds that come out in in
Jurassic world the ones that drop people
I was gonna say those are the guy with
me gal with mamas is that what they like
the ones that are just roaming on the
Prairie in the first Jurassic Park yes
so real quick it is all the dress it's
dinos in Jurassic Park only oh okay yeah
okay that would have been good to know
so start that off but yes it's the
Gallimimus
I'm impressed I'm pretty pretty
impressed Ellis you must be real cool
back in 93. I'm three for three
um now that we know it's the original
Jurassic Park movies or the original
Jurassic Park movie let's get one more
dino noise and see I'm gonna turn it
back over to Jacqueline who's enthralled
by this game and I want Jacqueline to
nail this one here we go
that liquidy yeah
I'm not enthralled it's that I don't
know what their names are so I don't
want to say what I have to say now which
is dinosaur with the next spit like
that's what I have to say because I'm
not a paleontologist so that's more
helpful to me than the real name yeah
the dinosaur with the next bit people
know what that means that nobody knows
it's the dilophosaurus Dilophosaurus
that's literally why this game the
minute you said I was like I don't know
what to flip these dinos names we can
take non-scientific answers it's all the
it's all I appreciate you dumbing it
down for me but that's literally what I
was thinking it's like I don't know the
name of these things
I Brian do you have any more do you have
any more sound effects for us
this game all day if he could
what the hell was that the was that the
Velociraptor stock yeah that had to have
been ding ding ding ding and fun fact
that is actually tortoises having sex
yeah so that's important of watching
paint dry the the the sound designer who
wanted an Oscar for this or was
nominated for it literally recorded all
different kinds of animals doing all
sorts of activities and when the
Velociraptors bark at each other it's
literally two tortoises making that
sweet love did I ever tell you all my uh
my tortoise threesome story so I I
stopped over at a zoo in Florida a few
years ago and they had a tortoise pen
these are like giant tortoises and I saw
two tortoises kind of like making eyes
at each other and then a third one gets
involved and it was a literal tortoise
threesome I have video footage of it
somewhere I gotta find it on my phone
but I filmed a tortoise porn three
tortoises all going at it it was like
the two of them and then the one came
over to fix the plumbing and it was just
a beautiful moment of of tortoise coitus
expression
they're like they're at the park they're
like sir you've been here for two hours
you need to stop filming the tortoises
you're making everyone uncomfortable
this is where I first discovered just
how tortoise is mating is and I'm not
gonna lie to you they are very loud and
they like rabbits have the wrong sort of
I would say like Rumor Mill behind them
they should have tortoises like those
like little turtles they are about about
it they overtook all of the ponds in ut
nothing else can be there they bully
everybody else out yeah the turtles I'm
just gonna leave it at this when you
watch Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
there's a reason why Raphael is so
ornery all the time dude just needs to
go to a club a certain kind of Club
Master Splinter you gotta let them do
this all right I mean they are teenagers
how much privacy a sewer accused
this is going down this road let's keep
going we've got time we got time this is
why we have that thing that always saves
us we're gonna transition to mailbag
[Music]
foreign
good ranking good uh walk down memory
lane with the original Jurassic Park as
well as recapping some of the action in
Jurassic world Dominion which is now in
theaters and now we're going to go to
ketchup crew member Wes Cunningham y'all
can be like Wes if you're watching or
listening to us just email us anytime RT
is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com Wes's movie is Days
of Thunder the Top Gun of NASCAR this
Tom Cruise Blockbuster has a cult
following that is loved by many but is
also hated by many the audience score is
fresh at 60 but critics and NASCAR
itself tore it apart but it is a highly
rewatchable movie and is an entertaining
Thrill Ride and yes in its own way seems
to follow Don Simpson Jerry
bruckheimer's 1986 classic Top Gun to a
t one of your favorite movies Mark well
that's right Wes with Tom Cruise flying
high and crushing at the box office with
top gun Maverick right now Days of
Thunder might be an interesting talk for
the times this is still early in Cruz's
career and it's his first movie with
Nicole Kidman so if you all like going
fast and turning to the left then review
this movie still love listening to you
too and your guests and remember Robin
is racing West C thank you Wes I would
love to talk uh the Top Gun of NASCAR
Days of Thunder Jack when you were Days
of Thunder gal yeah I don't know if I
would really want to be talking about it
that movie like good luck to Mark
Hoffmeyer on the trivia on that one
there's a lot there's a lot about that
movie it's one of those ones it's like
you shouldn't dig too deep into the
production of it so do you uh you a big
days of thunderhunk you know I think
I've only seen it once and it was like
back in the 90s or maybe early 2000s so
I I don't know I think maybe it has and
Mark Hoffmeyer expert researcher would
appreciate this comment it has possibly
the best rental car racing scene in
movie history Mark Hoffmeyer would
appreciate that I would vote if we're
gonna do early Tom Cruise I would vote
for legend the Ridley Scott Adventure
pick where it's like fantasy Tom Cruise
does a slightly androgynous warrior with
like the very long like before he did
The Last Samurai long hair and before he
did a magnolia he did it in Legend it
was a preview of things to come ladies
and gentlemen can I tell you Something's
Gonna blow your mind and it might sway
producing Lucy towards team Jacqueline
I've never seen Legend yeah you
absolutely should yeah no I think that's
a also Tim Curry in mounds of makeup
giving one of the most iconic
performances of his career a whole score
controversy between Jerry Goldsmith and
tangerine dream ladies and gentlemen oh
my gosh and also Jacqueline you know
Satan in that movie or the devil or
whatever that character is he's not
scary that little fairy child is scary
because peeking through the door with
its like light eyes I that was like one
of my first
nightmares as a child because that's
right I watched it when I was like six
years old oh no that was very much in
that like secret of the name returned to
Oz like when they used to scare children
that were born in the early or mid 80s
when they're throughout the early 90s
you went on Legend uh I I think I've
definitely seen it more than Days of
Thunder but it's honestly still for me
like I started paying a lot more
attention to him a little bit later in
his career I feel like but Legend I know
is is pretty great there's some pretty
great moments in there and yes like
Jacqueline said it does preview things
to come with them I'm gonna give you all
expenses paid trip to Jurassic world for
a weekend and we'll screen the legend
there then they would go I don't even
know if I like them that much
I have the movie at home
and I can watch it without Dino teeth
coming in contact with my very delicate
I'm Taking My Chances I'm gonna go to
Jimmy Buffett's Margaritaville I'm going
to Jurassic world I would go to the
first Jurassic Park I would not um pull
a lawyer in the first Jurassic Park but
I would go and I would probably have a
good time and I think I'd survive I'm
gonna give myself that credit uh Andrew
guy has a burgeoning film career that is
about to take liftoff at various film
festivals maybe one near you make sure
that y'all keep tabs on a Bogota trip
and always Lola Andrew do we have any
release date in town either one of those
are they just making the festival rounds
right now uh right now it's just the
festival rounds we're hoping for
distribution like later on in the year
around fall or maybe even the winter
time but if you are in La it's it's June
20th and 22nd but you guys can just
follow me on Twitter at Andrew guy
that's probably the best way to do it
I'll be posting more information there
and yeah man I mean I love being here
thanks for having me back and also to
talk we talked Top Gun in Jurassic Park
I don't know if anyone's ever had a
better one-two punch on this show you're
having a pretty good pretty good run on
this show and a pretty good run in your
career young man so congratulations on
on all your success and all that is to
come do you have a movie or TV
recommendation that is currently being
streamed at the guy household what what
is Snickers your your magical dog
watching right now
I feel like all the other one like oh go
watch Severance you'd be like you told
me to do that like two months ago so I
don't want to be that guy but I do love
Severance but I'll say one that is a
little bit less swatched that I was
actually pleasantly surprised by was
candy on Hulu with Jessica Biel I
thought it was pretty good and it's
based off a true story and I think it's
like only eight episodes and it's it's
pretty pretty compelling so um yeah I I
check that out I liked it all right I'm
in on candy and that is once again
Andrew Guy can follow him on all various
social media platforms until next time
for Andrew Guy our esteemed guest here
he is a great announcer as well he's a
great host you can catch him talking
Esports all over the world the movie
trivia Showdown occasionally thanks for
joining us Andrew our incredible
engineer Brian Perez who this was not
actually lifted from the movie that was
actually Brian Perez doing all those
dinosaur Impressions so thank you Brian
for handling that you're the Michael
Winslow of dinosaurs producing Lucy and
my incredible co-host Jacqueline Coley
who I'm getting word is still not going
to Jurassic World unlike me who will
definitely be in attendance I am Millie
Mark Ellis for the whole gang here at
Rotten Tomatoes and our show Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong thanks for watching
we'll see you next week dinosaurs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]